welcome to epigenetics three histone
modification and chromatin
immunoprecipitation in this course we
will explore how gene expression is
controlled by histones and how histone
modification can be studied using
specialized protocols like chromatin
immunoprecipitation we will also discuss
analytical approaches to study genome
wide histone modification data or chip
seek and specific challenges these
methods are designed to address before
we jump in let's first do a quick
overview of epigenetic regulation and
discuss the significance of histone
modification as you remember from
previous courses epigenetics is the
study of mechanisms that cause changes
in gene expression but that are not
encoded in the DNA sequence itself these
mechanisms include DNA methylation
histone modification activity of
non-coding RNAs such as micro RNAs and
the regulatory function of non-coding
repeating regions found in the DNA
histone modification is a major aspect
of epigenetic regulation histones are
proteins that the double-stranded DNA is
wrapped around on these images you can
see how the DNA string has small bumps
or beads on it these visible beads are
nucleosomes that are made up of histones
when these beads were originally
discovered scientists confused them with
jeans until was eventually proven that
the string like structure is wrapped
around and not to beat themselves
actually contain the genetic code
histones can be either grouped together
forming lumps of DNA or as we can see in
the picture on the right more relaxed
and spread out it turns out that the
modification of histones plays a major
role in how densely the histones are
grouped together or spread apart
moreover additional modifications of
histone tails can have other effects on
gene transcription one important aspect
of histones is that they can be changed
to alter how much packing the DNA is
capable of there are several key
modifications that take place as a
result of changes to groups of atoms
that are at the ends of histones these
changes can be of several types and will
have a positive or negative charge that
either attract them closer together or
force them apart as a result the DNA
region that is wrapped around the head
stones can be more or less accessible
causing variation in gene expression the
nucleosome is considered to be the basic
repeating unit of chromatin in which 146
base pairs of DNA are wrapped around an
octamer of core histones consisting of
pairs of h3 h4 h2a and h2b n terminal
tails of these systems protrude out of
the nucleosome and are subject to a
variety of post translational
modifications such as acetylation
phosphorylation ubiquitination
and lysine and arginine methylation a
set elation was the first of these
modifications to be linked with active
transcription and subsequently
phosphorylation of histone h3 was found
to cooperate with a substation in
transcriptional activation some histone
methylation events have also been
associated with transcription activation
and others with gene silencing histone
modifications can function either
individually or combinatorially to
govern such processes as transcription
replication DNA repair and apoptosis it
has been proposed that methyl group of
atoms increases packing and a central
group decreases packing also phosphoryl
group can be attached to the histones
and causes a decrease in packing these
modifications and their impact on
transcription and other processes are
being actively studied and as our
understanding grows researchers
appreciate how complex this machinery
works in real life as we mentioned
histones are organized in october's
forming nucleosomes the four histones
are called h-2a h-2b h3 and h4 DNA is
wrapped around with structure of four
times with histone h1 holding everything
together the most studied modification
of histones are methylation in a set
elation of the core histone tails as you
can see modification to the tails of
histones is linked to the length of the
tail itself when a specific type of the
modification is studied it will be
referred to as h3k4me3 or h3k27 me3 the
name simply refers to the position on
histone tail and the type of
modification it is
here you can see a table of histone
modifications and their reported impact
on transcription for example you might
read about h3k4 methylation free signal
this means that h3 histone tail is being
modified by removal of methyl group
items different signals act as different
regulatory mechanisms and sometimes work
together in the complex patterns the
function of specific histone
modifications is an active field of
research and many of these modifications
are not yet known on the right you can
see how these modifications and appear
in chip seek data against the control
sample to understand this better let's
discuss chromatin immunoprecipitation
for studying histone modification
chromatin immunoprecipitation followed
by high-throughput sequencing for chip
seek is a powerful tool to identify
genome-wide profiles of transcription
factor binding sites histone
modifications and nucleosome positioning
to understand the way this data is
generated we have to look at the process
in greater detail and appreciate the
biological elements involved in various
steps of the chip seek protocol
chromatin immunoprecipitation uses
antibodies designed to bind to specific
proteins of interest for pris
these can be histones or other complexes
attached to the DNA first cross-linking
ensures the proteins are tightly bound
to DNA so that DNA shattering does not
remove them
DNA is shattered leaving fragments of
DNA with or without protein of interest
on them special antibodies bind to
fragments of DNA with proteins of
interest the antibodies are typically
attached to magnetic beads so that it
can be used to extract fragments of DNA
with protein antibody complexes the
complexes can then be removed and
libraries for sequencing are prepared
the sequence reads will contain tags
that are used to denote the position
next to where the protein was bound to
DNA as a result peaks of reads will
accumulate next to positions of DNA
bound to protein in the analysis that
these positions are identified Peaks
quantified and position of the protein
binding site is determined accumulation
of reads with tags is analyzed for
accurate detection of binding sites to
detect accumulation properly a second
library called I DNA is prepared as a
control abundance of reads vs. control
provides assessment of abundant
significance then reads align to
positive and negative strands are
analyzed for overlap helping select the
exact position of PRI binding sites a
key step for chromatin
immunoprecipitation is the design of an
antibody that binds to a specific
protein for example you might have a kid
for histone h3 or even more specific to
h3k27 or h3k4 specificity of the
antibody whether it is monoclonal or
polyclonal and the organism it is
specific for are all key factors in
generating high quality data the whole
process of data preparation looks like
this proteins of interest like histones
are bound to DNA DNA is fragmented
resulting in DNA fragments that have
protein of interest on them and others
that do not they might have other
proteins on them or nothing at all only
DNA with proteins of interest bound to
them or event
they're selected with specially designed
antibodies the DNA is then separated
from the protein and the DNA fragments
sequenced as a result reads that were in
the region bound to the protein of
interest can be aligned to the reference
genome and regions with abundance of
reads are analyzed when we deal with
chip sig data we are analyzing sequences
of short reads that came from DNA
fragments that were attached to protein
of interest we selected after we
sequence the raw reads they need to be
cleaned from adapter sequences and PCR
duplicates then - they're cleaned reads
are aligned to the positive and negative
strands of the DNA separately this is
done because when the DNA is wrapped
around the protein of interest and
fragmented there will be a slight shift
to the left or right left from the
positive strand and right from the
negative string that needs to be
accounted for then the challenge is to
accurately identify Peaks what is
commonly referred to as peak Collin peak
calling is performed on the two strands
separately which leads to the next step
determining the position of the p/y
Center by shifting the positive and
negative strand reads and identifying
the intersecting segments finally the
intersecting segments are annotated and
marked as positions where the DNA was
wrapped around a py the major objective
of chip seek analysis to detect genome
fragments that are enriched with
upregulated signals these fragments
could be transcription factor binding
sites chromatin remodeling or gene
transcription events the main
algorithmic challenge is to accurately
detect enriched genome fragments
generating a whole genome landscape for
the signal to do that let's review
several techniques related to peak
detection and peak shift that are part
of the chip seek workflow probably the
most discussed issue and chip seek
experiments is the best method to find
true peaks in the data and precisely
identify a binding site a peak is a site
where multiple reads have been mapped to
and produce a pilot to accurately assess
the pilot significance a control library
is often used also referred to as I DNA
chip sequencing is most often performed
with single and reads and chip fragments
per sequence from the five prime ends
only this creates two disty
pekes one on each strand with the
binding site fallen in the middle of
these Peaks the distance from the middle
of the peaks to the binding site is
often referred to as the shift as the
DNA is wrapped around the histones and
can be more or less accessible various
portions of the DNA are affected these
include the promoter region
transcription start sites and the
introns and exons of genes other
regulatory regions like enhancers and
micro rna's are encoded in introns or in
proximity to coding regions each one of
these elements can have a significant
effect on the level of gene expression
alternative splicing as well as other
downstream regulation of pathways the
size of the region and its location are
both important
researchers are reporting that different
histone modifications are associated
with specific widths and profiles of
Peaks that can be detected in chip seek
data often times specific regions like
enhancers and transcription factors or
micro RNAs are being studied in cancer
neurodegenerative diseases and other
conditions researchers are studying one
or multiple types of modifications and
the elements they regulate by comparing
chip seek profiles of groups of samples
accurate identification of differential
profiles of histone modification can
lead to the understanding of epigenetic
regulation specific to a condition now
that we understand the way chip seek
data is prepared and analyzed let us try
to perform an analysis ourselves in this
hands-on section we will build a simple
pipeline to analyze the data and discuss
methods that were used in pipeline
results Before we jump in to building
our pipeline let's review the options we
have for analysis the two options are
for analysis of Peaks in a given sample
or for detecting differences between two
conditions in our case we will use the I
DNA option to identify areas that have
histone modifications by comparing a
condition versus control the condition
we will study is Engelmann syndrome an
inherited neurodegenerative disease
Engelmann syndrome also known as a s is
a neurogenic disorder caused by deletion
of the maternally inherited ube 3a
allele and is characterized by the
development delay
intellectual disability ataxia seizures
and a happy effect it is believed to be
caused by epigenetic deregulation of a
region that is responsible for proper
neuron differentiation we will use a
pair of samples from the study to try a
hands-on analysis of chip seek data the
full article is available here let's
navigate to server dot T - bio info and
open the areas of analysis here you will
see a dedicated section for analysis of
chip on chip and chip seek data when you
are in select single and reads as e and
Homo sapiens grch38 for reference genome
we already have to fast queue files in
SRA format archive of sequence reads
uploaded to the server so we don't have
to wait for lengthy uploads over various
connection speeds SR are five nine nine
zero eight eight five is a healthy
control sample and SR are five nine nine
zero eight eight two is a cell line from
a patient with angleman syndrome we can
place the healthy and sample group and
sick and I DNA essentially we will get a
contrast between the two so it does not
matter which one goes where our first
pipeline will be very simple for now
let's skip the pre-processing steps and
discuss two central processing steps
alignment and segmentation alignment or
mapping as it is also called can be done
with several methods the main goal is to
align reads to the reference genome we
selected Homo sapiens grch38 both i2g is
a newer version of the bowtie algorithm
that was published in 2012 the second
main step in the analysis of map reads
is accurate detection of the rich
regions for this purpose we will use
Isaac a method that uses a Bayesian
hidden Ising model for chip seek data to
ignore falsely enriched regions caused
by sequencing and/or mapping errors
another more complete pipeline is shown
here the main change is with including
PCR clean to remove PCR duplicates and
using multiple methods for segmentation
these include Binh s a segmentation
method developed by the Taliban from
Alex
research center and max to the popular
method for analysis of chip seek data
penis algorithm is based on a method
developed by broadsky Adele in 2010
called the binary search approach to
whole genome data analysis this dividing
conquer type algorithm detects a series
of non-interest in fragments of various
lengths with locally optimal scores
original version of blacks - was
published by Ying chieh and Cao Lu Lu
from the lab of extra Li Lu at the
dana-farber Cancer Institute Boston here
we will use version two developed and
maintained by taolu as a result of the
second pipeline we can use mapping
statistics as well as a table of each
chromosome
let's select from some one to see what
the output looks like in the output
table you will see a number of columns
corresponding to outputs by each method
bin s I seek and max - the most reliable
results will be when we each method
gives an enrichment score significantly
greater than zero for example these
positions highlighted between nine
hundred sixty one thousand two hundred
and 960 1800 on chromosome one since the
output is already annotated we can see
this segment corresponds with NS G zero
zero zero zero zero one eight seven nine
six one this is KLH seventeen catch like
family member 17 let's look at this gene
in greater detail the protein encoded by
this gene is expressed in neurons of
most regions of the brain it contains an
n-terminal BTB domain which mediates
dimerization of the protein na seed
terminal Kelch domain which mediates
binding to f-actin this protein may play
a key role in the regulation of actin
based neuronal function KHL 17 has been
reported to be involved in neural
development for example in their study
of infantile spasms I assess pack yakov
ski at I'll link a leech l7 theme to
expansion of epilepsy phenotypes as you
can see in this chart where enrichment
scores from I seek
were plotted KHL 17 is only one of the
genes identified by enrichment of reeds
as you remember these reeds mark a
protein of interest attached to the DNA
reading deeper into the method section
of the paper we can find what antibody
they used for preparing their chip seek
data the protein of interest what was
h3k4me3 if we plot the scores on the
scatterplot with y-axis and the position
on the chromosome we will see that KHL
17 is at the start of the chromosome one
of the first and rich regions identified
by all three algorithms but that is not
the only region that we can see highly
enriched in this type of methylation of
h3 histone we also see another region
around the 150 million position that
stands out one of the ways we can gauge
the significance of the whole region is
to use David for enrichment with gene
ontology terms now that you have this
data you are welcome to play around with
these enriched regions to see what you
can discover thank you for taking this
course and we hope that you enjoyed
learning about epigenomics data analysis
if you want to take things further
we recommend diving deeper into the
Engelmann project or this other project
focused on asthma to help you get
started with these datasets we've
prepared guides on accessing all of the
data that include chip seek my sulphate
seek and RNA sequence that's in the
project you will find data guides and
explanations of methods you can rely on
analyzing and integrating this multi
onyx data